[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMY UNRUH: So welcome, everyone.
A few of my colleagues
actually thought that--
they read the title
too quickly and they
thought that this was a talk
about preventing over-fitting
with machine learning.
So if any of you are
here because that's
what you think
it's about, I want
to assure you it'll be just as
interesting, even though it's
about overfishing.
DAVID KROODSMA: We do
address over-fitting.
Well, not in this
talk, but in the thing.
Anyway.
Hi, my name is David Kroodsma.
I'm the Research
Program Director
at SkyTruth, which is a small
nonprofit that does big data
analytics, and uses
satellites to monitor
environmental challenges.
The main project I work on
is Global Fishing Watch,
which is the main thing
we'll be talking about today.
My background is in physics
and earth systems science.
And I am both fascinated
by and deeply concerned
by the human impact on the
globe, and very excited about
the role of data in better
understanding and addressing
those challenges.
AMY UNRUH: And I'm Amy Unruh.
I am in Developer Relations on
the Cloud Platform at Google.
And so how this came
about is I originally
proposed a Google Next
talk that was essentially
on the same topic in terms of
the underlying infrastructure
that Global Fishing
Watch is using.
And so then after I
had proposed that,
I attended an
internal talk, where
I learned about
Global Fishing Watch,
and I was extremely enthused.
And so we joined forces.
And so you're going to
hear about a lot of really
interesting tech solving
real-world problems.
DAVID KROODSMA: And
so the first thing
we're going to talk today
about is Global Fishing Watch,
which is this project.
And we should say right away
that Global Fishing Watch is
a partnership between
SkyTruth, where I work,
Oceana, a oceans conservation
nonprofit, and Google,
which is one reason that
I'm working with Amy.
AMY UNRUH: But the slides don't
seem to be advancing properly,
by the way.
DAVID KROODSMA: We see
it right here, though.
AMY UNRUH: Yeah.
We see it on our--
DAVID KROODSMA: Just
turn the laptop around.
AMY UNRUH: There we go.
So we're going to talk about
how Global Fishing Watch uses
Google Cloud Platform products.
And in particular
for this talk, we're
going to focus on Cloud Dataflow
TensorFlow, Cloud ML Engine.
They also use BigQuery
and GCS a lot.
And we'll also talk about how
we can take what Global Fishing
Watch is using sort of as
a basis for doing something
new to generate close
to real-time insights
about the things that
they're tracking.
DAVID KROODSMA: So
Global Fishing Watch.
So who here has gone fishing?
Most of you.
Who here has been on an
industrial fishing boat
at some point in their life?
Where was it?
And what was it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID KROODSMA: OK.
So I probably won't be
able to find that boat.
But most of us when we think
of fishing, think of this.
And this is what
I do as fishing.
And this is what most people do.
But most of the world's
fish are actually
caught by boats like this.
This is a picture of China.
Each of these boats is
about 100-feet long.
And the way that China
manages its fishery in order
to prevent overfishing is they
have a three-month moratorium
on fishing.
At the end of which, everyone
is allowed to go out.
And this is at the
end of the moratorium
when all the fishing vessels are
about to go out to the ocean.
And so that gives
you a sense when
you can see all the boats at
once, just what is heading out
for you if you're a fish.
And this is really
remarkable, but this is not
to pick on China.
This is happening
all over the world.
And you know, it goes over out
into the ocean and extracts
fish from this shared
global resource.
And it's kind of an ultimate
tragedy of the commons.
And the reason we
care about this
is because fishing is
such a huge problem.
So about 1 billion
people in the world
rely on fish as their
primary source of protein,
but the oceans are
very overfished.
90% of apex species have
disappeared in our lifetime.
So that's big things
like shark and tuna.
About 85% of the
world's fisheries
are either overfished,
at capacity,
or recovering from having
already been overfished.
And perhaps the most
important number
here is this one, 1 in 5, which
is the amount of fish which,
as we call IUU, or Illegal,
Unregulated, or Undocumented.
Potentially, it's fish where we
don't know where it came from.
And if you imagine you have
a huge shared resource,
and you're not even able
to measure where 20% of it
comes from, that's one of
the reasons you're going
to have an overfishing problem.
At the same time, this
is a problem which really
requires a global approach.
38% of fish is traded
internationally.
55% comes from developing
countries with an export
value of $60 billion.
So in summary, overfishing
is a huge problem.
It desperately
needs transparency
and requires a global
approach to address,
which is why we developed
Global Fishing Watch.
So Global Fishing
Watch takes data
from transceivers on boats which
broadcasts their locations.
And these are big, industrial
boats, not the small ones.
And maps out how
they're moving, and then
identifies where and
when fishing is talking.
If you go to
globalfishingwatch.org,
you can look at our map.
It's almost near real-time.
So it shows fishing from
3 days ago to 5 years ago.
And it looks like this.
It animates and shows you
where fishing is happening.
I love looking at this because
every time you look at it,
I see something new.
You can see patterns of
fishing along the equator,
where there's upwelling
bringing nutrients.
A lot of tuna fishing
happens there.
You can see fishing all
along the continental shelves
because that's where
a lot of nutrients
are, a lot of fishing is.
You can see political
boundaries where
a lot of some type
of fishing vessels
aren't allowed to fish within
certain country waters,
so they fish right
along the edge of it.
And you can also
see where people
don't respect the boundaries
of different countries,
like you can see
Australia right there.
You can see fishing happening
right along the edge of it.
You can see in Africa people
ignoring some of those lines.
So I'm going to now
switch to our website
so you can see
what it actually--
So you can click on
individual vessels.
So this is actually
our live website.
And you can watch them move.
So here, I clicked on this
one, which is the Chi Yang I.
And I should explain, each
of these little yellow dots
is where we think a
fishing activity happened.
And so if you hit
Play, you can now
watch where this boat is moving.
And this is a Malaysian
boat, the Chi Yang
I. It's a longliner, which means
it sets long lines of hooks.
Sometimes, as long as 100
kilometers, and then retrieves
them.
And so here, you can see
it moving back and forth
across the ocean.
And all the other dots are where
there's other boats fishing
here as well.
You can see
interesting patterns.
Such as here, here's an island
in the Southern Atlantic.
You can see fishing happening
right along the edge
where the continental
shelf ends.
And you can see that there
is clearly some type of geo--
some type of physical property
of the ocean where upwelling
happens right along the edge.
And that's where fishermen
are directing their boats.
And so there's all types
of interesting patterns
we can use to gain
insight in how
to better manage our oceans.
So that's the tool.
That's the exciting
thing we've built.
And we're going to spend the
rest of the time here talking
about how we built it.
And hopefully, then
empower you to be
able to do some of the same
types of machine learning
techniques.
So the core
technology to this is
called AIS, which stands for
the creatively named Automatic
Identification System,
which is something
that all large fishing
vessels are required to carry.
And it's a safety mechanism.
The idea is you broadcast your
location so that other boats
nearby can see where you are.
This is very important in
some parts of the ocean.
Here's a chart of boats
in the English Channel.
And all of these
boats want to make
sure they see where
the other ones are,
so they don't collide with them.
If you're in a boat with an
AIS device, it looks like this.
And you can see
it just brought--
you can see where all the
other boats are nearby you.
It tells you the name of that
boat, which direction it's
headed, its speed, all
types of useful information
to help you not collide with it.
These signals though, they
can be picked up by satellite.
And also, by receivers along
the land, terrestrial antennas.
In the last few
years, a few companies
have launched satellites
which collect this data,
and we have finally been able to
build a global database of AIS
signals.
And that is what we have been
collecting at Global Fishing
Watch and working with.
The AIS message looks like this.
It's an NMEA
message is the type.
There's a Googler who wrote a
library that we use to parse it
into a readable JSON file.
And this is what it looks like.
It has information about
the latitude, the longitude,
the course, the
speed, the heading,
as well as some
other information.
And we get about 20 million
of these data points a day.
As you can see, like
all other data graphs,
it's going up because
there's more now.
We have about half
a billion a month.
In 2012, you were getting far
fewer because fewer boats had
this technology.
And we had fewer satellites
and fewer terrestrial antennas.
So we're getting more and
more data every month.
And when you map out what all
the boats in the world look
like, it looks like this.
There's somewhere between
300,000 and 400,000 vessels
were AIS.
This is all of them, not
just fishing vessels.
And about 80,000 of these
are fishing vessels.
And that's what we identify
to determine fishing effort.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
So this is a lot of data.
When I started
looking at it, I was
startled to find that every day,
15 gigs was getting dumped--
of this data was getting dumped
into Google Cloud Storage.
And so not only is it a lot of
data to kind of shuffle around.
But if you're going to analyze
it in any meaningful way,
it requires a lot
of compute power.
And so Global Fishing
Watch would kind of
like to not have to
worry about that,
about shuffling large
amounts of data around,
about provisioning
VMs when they need it.
And so you can probably
guess the punchline--
Google Cloud platform
to the rescue.
So what I'm going to talk
about is the workflow
that they're using, and how
they put together some Cloud
platform products
to do what David
described on the
globalfishingwatch.org site.
And I'm going to focus for this
talk on Dataflow and Cloud ML
Engine.
But they're also making a
lot of use of other stuff.
In particular, BigQuery
and Cloud Storage.
David's going to talk a little
bit more about the BigQuery
later.
OK.
So this is kind of
a typical workflow.
And they actually
have several of them
that follow this pattern.
So first of all, a lot
of ship movement data.
Remember, it's like
about 15 gigs of day,
is getting dumped
into Cloud Storage.
And then, periodically
in batch mode,
they're running Dataflow
jobs to process this data,
to transform it,
to aggregate it.
And the output of that Dataflow
batch pipeline is features.
Using the term in
the sense of input
to a machine learning model.
So the outputting data that
is cleansed and aggregated
and transformed into
something that they
want to feed into
a TensorFlow model.
So then you can probably guess
the next part of this workflow
is TensorFlow and
Cloud ML Engine.
The features are
being generated.
And then, there are
sort of three parts
to what happens next.
So the first part is generating
the training data, of course.
And as those of you who
have done this kind of thing
might know, that can definitely
be non-trivial at times.
David is going to talk a
little more about that.
And then, they've built
some very interesting
convolutional neural nets
to do classification.
You'll hear a little
bit more about those.
So label the training
data, train the model.
So they're using
Cloud ML Engine to do
distributed training of the
model, of the TensorFlow model.
And then once the
model is trained,
they use it for inference.
So to dive a little
bit more into some
of the pieces of this.
So probably some of
you who have been
to talks that go into
this in more detail,
but for those of
you who haven't, let
me say a little bit first about
Apache Beam and Cloud Dataflow.
So Apache Beam is a unified
model for building data
processing pipelines
that can handle
both bounded and unbounded data,
batch and stream processing.
And Apache Beam is
also a set of SDKs
for building these pipelines.
And one particularly
salient point
about the model for the
purposes of this talk
is the way that Beam does
event time processing.
So you can tell Beam, I want
you to analyze this data
with respect to the time
it arrived at the pipeline.
Or you can tell it, I want to
analyze this data with respect
to when it was
actually generated.
And we need to do that latter
thing for the Global Fishing
Watch data.
We want to say, do your
analysis with respect
to the time this was
actually logged by the ship.
So then, Cloud Dataflow
is a managed service
for executing these
Beam pipelines.
And one nice thing about it is
that it supports auto-scaling.
So it will provision
workers up and down
as it needs them while
it's running a big job.
OK.
So that was Dataflow, the
middle green piece there.
Let me talk a little bit about
TensorFlow and Cloud ML Engine.
So again, some of you have
probably heard about TensorFlow
in the past couple of days.
This is an open source
platform for doing
numerical computations
with data flow graphs.
But in particular,
it is particularly
good for building and training
deep neural net models.
It has a distributed runtime.
It supports
auto-differentiation.
It was sort of built
for deep learning.
So Cloud ML Engine,
which those of you
who attended yesterday's keynote
know has just gone to GA then,
is a managed service
for training,
doing distributed training
of your TensorFlow models.
With GPUs are now
available, if you like.
And then, for serving the
model once you've trained it.
So we'll talk a little
bit more about that later.
DAVID KROODSMA:
And I should note
that we've been using these
GPUs and see about a 10 times
improvement in our model
training and inference.
Using the GPUs over the CPUs
has been incredibly useful.
Especially right now, I'm
actually having some back
and forth with our
machine learning engineer
and doing lots of
iterations on the model,
and it's really helpful to
have those fast processors.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
So that was a workflow that
Global Fishing Watch is using.
But actually, it's much
more general than that.
And this is kind of a
useful and common design
pattern where you want to
do-- you've got a lot of data.
You want to do a lot of
pre-processing and feature
generation, and then you
want to train a model.
And so if you do this
all in the cloud,
you don't have to
worry about scaling up.
You don't have to worry about
shuffling very large amounts
of data around.
And that's kind of
what this suggests.
Do your pre-processing
with Dataflow,
send the result to Cloud ML
to do distributed training
of your TensorFlow model.
DAVID KROODSMA: I
want to talk now
about how we actually
built the net
and how we got the
training data for it.
So we have two main
classification problems
with Global Fishing Watch.
One is vessel identity.
So identifying what type of boat
it is and what type of fishing
it is doing.
It matters a lot
for conservation
and for marine spatial
planning whether or not
the boat is fishing
with a trawling
net, which drags
along the bottom,
or if it's fishing with
these long lines of hooks.
And they don't tell you what
it is in the AIS message,
so you have to look at how
the boat moves to identify it.
The second problem
is identifying
when they are actually
fishing and when
they're just transiting
from one place to the next.
So here, you can see these
are three of the major types
of fishing boats.
There is a trawler,
longliner, and purse seiner.
They move differently.
There is some pictures
of these large vessels.
And your eye can
see the difference
and so we can train a machine
to see a difference as well.
The hard part?
In order to train
this model, we had
to get a few thousand
examples of these boats.
And we did that by
matching the AIS data
to official registries,
which involved a lot of fuzzy
logic and fuzzy matching.
From that, we got a
few thousand boats,
from which we were
able to identify
a few hundred thousands boats.
And I should add
that we were also
identifying non-fishing boats.
Because remember, all the
boats with AIS, most of them
are not fishing boats.
So we have to be
able to tell what's
a tugboat, what's a longline
fishing boat, what's a tanker.
Second problem is identifying
when the boat is fishing.
And to do that,
ideally you would
have some logbook
from the captain that
would tell you
when and where they
put their gear in the water.
The problem is that,
1, captains rarely want
to give you that information.
And 2, when you get it,
usually it's not exactly right.
For instance, the latitude and
longitude may be slightly off
or the time stamp may be
in the wrong time zone.
And so it's much
easier and sometimes
more reliable to just look
at the tracks and hand label
where you think
they are fishing.
And so this is what we did.
And this was very, very tedious.
I built a small
JavaScript interface
through PYBOSSA, an open source
platform for crowdsourcing.
And then, basically messaged
everyone on Slack every day
to tell them they
had to do more tasks.
And we made a little
competition out of it.
Don't let Christian
crush us this week.
And this went on for
about six weeks every day,
until we had labeled a few
hundred thousand points.
And this is one
of the main things
about this machine
learning techniques
I've learned is that--
how one of the major efforts
is getting the training data
and getting it in the
right position before you
can even do any of the
fun model building.
Our first algorithm
on fishing was
a simple logistic regression
trained on the average speed,
the standard deviation of speed,
and the standard deviation
of course as well
as those features
squared across a few
different time windows.
The whole idea is, if a boat
is moving slowly, wiggling,
and changing direction,
it's more likely fishing.
And that model did
relatively well in accuracy.
Overall accuracy, I
think just under 0.8.
But then we've decided
we wanted to do--
both for identifying
specific vessels and
for identifying
this fishing effort,
we wanted to build
a neural network
to do this because we thought
we could do a little bit better.
And the problem with
using a neural network
is just the sheer
number of points.
So you can think about it.
We want to look at the
whole path of a boat.
And so you take maybe 10,000
data points of where it's been.
And for each of
those data points,
you have like 10
different features,
such as the speed,
such as the course,
such as the distance from
shore, the time of day.
And you want to use
all that information
to tell whether or not
what type of boat it is
and whether it's fishing.
So that's 10 features per
point and 10,000 points.
That's over 100,000 features.
You can't easily run a
fully-connected neural network
on that, so we built a
convolutional neural net that
does a convolution in time.
And what that does is we
have 9 of these convolutions
and that takes more
than 100,000 features
and brings it down to
around 2,000 features.
And then after that, we have
2 fully-connected layers.
And that brings us down
to a little over a dozen
different vessel classes.
And then we have a
similar architecture
which figures out the--
looks at each point and
identifies whether or not
we think it is fishing.
This is the detailed
architecture
of the identification model.
We're also identifying the
length and the engine power
and the weight of these boats.
Obviously, I'm not
going to go over this,
but we're working on
a scientific paper
to write up these findings.
And you'll be able
to read much more
about that in the supplemental
materials of that paper.
So how does it work?
It works pretty well.
Here's a confusion matrix of
how the classification does
on our different classes.
These are the different classes.
The top one is cargo or tanker.
Reefer is a type of
cargo vessel for fishing.
And so you can see it
actually confuses it
with something that you would
expect it to, because they're
very similar types of boats.
But for fishing boats, which
are all down on the bottom,
it rarely confuses them
with non-fishing boats.
So we're pretty happy
with this overall.
And then, identifying
fishing activity.
It's a little bit better
than the logistic model.
And we're making
some adjustments
to make even better than that.
So it performs better than
the logistic, which is good.
And we can, for the
first time, build maps
like this, which is where
we think trawlers are
fishing in the world's oceans.
And trawlers usually
stay close to the coast
because they drag their
nets along the ocean floor.
So this is a map where we
think all trawlers were
fishing in 2016.
This is longliners.
They set drifting long
lines out in the ocean,
and so they cover
all the oceans.
And then, purse seiners,
which set these nets
around schools of fish.
Often, tuna.
And you can see them
fishing along the equator
as well as off the
coasts of some countries.
Again, why does this matter?
Why do we care about identifying
where and when fishing happens?
Well, here is-- I shouldn't
have showed that yet.
Anyway.
So this is a map of the Central
Pacific in Global Fishing
Watch.
And I'm going to zoom into
the country, Kiribati.
Halfway between-- oops.
So the country Kiribati has the
world's largest marine UNESCO
World Heritage site.
Can you see it on this map?
It is right there.
So even though it was a
World Heritage-- and this
is from 2014.
Even though it as a
World Heritage site,
industrial fishing
was still allowed.
So you see lots of
these yellow dots in it.
However, on January 1, 2015,
the President of Kiribati
decided to make fishing,
industrial fishing,
illegal in this area, the
Phoenix Islands Protected Area,
or PIPA.
And so all boats were
going to have to clear out.
And so the question
was, could we
use Global Fishing Watch
to identify whether or not
this new boundary
was being obeyed?
And I should emphasize, this
is the size of California,
that red box.
Care is one of the
world's poorest countries.
They have like one patrol
boat for that entire thing.
So imagine you have to patrol
California with one boat.
And so what we did is you kind
of wait to see what happens.
And now it's playing forward.
This is a 2-month
period of time.
And now we're into 2015, a
little bit of 2014 still.
And as we get into all
of 2015, they clear out.
And we know the
boats didn't just
turn off their AIS
because we were
able to track what
happened to all those boats
that left and saw that they
actually went somewhere else
and fished.
And so it's really
exciting that we're
able to identify this park.
Now, a few months after it
closed, a boat, the Marshalls
203, we saw fishing just right
inside the line right there.
And Kiribati authorities were
notified, and they went--
and their one boat escorted that
fishing vessel back to port.
And they went to the
captain and said,
you are fishing illegally.
We want to fine
you for doing this.
And the captain said, you
can't prove I was fishing.
How do you know?
I'll see you in court.
And so they actually called
up SkyTruth and Global Fishing
Watch and said, hey, can
you guys look at this boat
and see how it is moving,
tell us whether it was fishing
or not?
And we sent them
basically something
like this with an analysis
on it as well as the results
of our fishing algorithm.
They showed that to
the captain of the boat
and he said, OK, I'll settle.
And it resulted in a $2
million fine, which is about 1%
of the country's GDP.
And so it was extremely--
[APPLAUSE]
I also enjoy a lot of
data science work on this.
So once we have this big
data set, there's a lot of--
we want to be able to look in
all different types of way.
But it's still
several terabytes.
And so we load it into BigQuery,
and then use various tools
to query and BigQuery to
slice in different ways.
And this is an example.
I do a lot of work like this.
This is an IPython notebook.
I run the write I wrote
to write a query to make
this graphic, which it's
not impressionist art.
Someone saw this and
said, congratulations.
But what this is, is the
x-axis is the day of the year.
The y-axis is degrees latitude.
And so you can see when and
where fishing is happening.
You can see we have a lot
more fishing in the Northern
Hemisphere.
That's partially
because our data set.
You can see people
take the weekends off.
That's what each of
those stripes are.
You can see that
three-month closure period I
was telling you about in China.
You can also see
that China actually--
people in China don't take
the weekends off as much as
in North America and Europe.
And you can see other things.
You can see that in Antarctica,
there's very little fishing.
And it happens only in
the Antarctic summer.
And what's exciting
about this is
every time I look
at this data, I
make kind of a new
discovery, something
no one's ever seen before.
And that's only possible because
we have these big data tools,
like BigQuery, that
allow us to quickly slice
this data in different ways.
We also are starting to
use Earth Engine, which
is a Google platform that
allows you to do calculations
on very large rasters.
So we can actually make our
data, turn it into a raster,
and load it into
Earth Engine, and then
look at how it compares
to various climatological
or other types of
global data sets.
And this just shows where all
the vessels from Spain fish.
And actually, it's
quite remarkable
if you look at how
much Spain is fishing
all over the world's oceans.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
So this is where I
came into the story.
So I wanted to see--
this is obviously
very, very cool stuff.
So I wanted to
see, what would it
take to basically
build on top of this,
to see if we could generate
close to real-time predictions
of fishing activity as
all this data gets dumped
into cloud storage every day?
So it turns out that
the answer is yes.
And it was pretty
straightforward.
I was able to do what
I'm going to talk about
in just a few weeks.
And very little
needed to be changed
in terms of how I hooked into
what they had already built.
And so primary
reason for that is
that it's very straightforward
to take the Dataflow pipeline
that we talked about earlier,
that Global Fishing Watch has
been running in batch, using
to generate feature data.
Because Beam has this unified
streaming batch model,
it was very straightforward
to turn this
into a streaming pipeline.
And so essentially,
all I had to do
was to change the so-called
sources and syncs, the inputs
and outputs of the pipeline.
So I did some work
to stream data
into the pipeline using Pub/Sub.
And then, the pipeline was
also modified to emit data
to another Pub/Sub topic.
So streaming in, streaming out.
But the logic of the
pipeline could stay the same.
And so that was really nice.
It was really straightforward.
And then I added a
new pipeline that
consumed that output stream and
did some further derivations
using the derived features.
And using Cloud ML Engine and
the trained TensorFlow model
to make predictions about where
fishing activity was happening.
So this was the second
of the two models
that David was talking
about, the model
that predicts fishing activity.
OK.
So what this second
pipeline does
is basically surface
in near real-time,
where are the fishing activity
hotspots at a given time?
So let me show you what
kind of the result of that,
and then I'll dig into the
tech that made it work.
So this is being displayed
on CARTO, a cool site.
This is real data from
a couple of weeks ago.
And when I hit Play,
what it's going to show
is basically, over the course
of about 10 days, what fishing
activity hotspots did we find?
So the heat maps are
just showing magnitude
of fishing in the area.
It might have been
more than one boat.
And over time, you can
see those shift around.
It's even a little more dramatic
if I zoom out a bit here.
OK.
So you can think of this
as being in near real time.
As the data comes in,
we're saying, all right.
There's fishing activity here.
There's fishing activity here
at a given point in time.
And then, we kind of have
a sliding time window.
And so that can help Global
Fishing Watch give them
indication--
early indication that
fishing is happening
where it shouldn't,
or if there's
things they want to focus
on in their larger batch
analytics that doesn't
look quite right in terms
of where people
should be fishing
in a given time of year.
OK.
So now, let's look at what
went into that under the hood.
So here's just kind
of at a high level
the logic of this second
pipeline that I built. So input
are these derived features
from the first original Global
Fishing Watch pipeline.
And again, using features
in the sense of input
to their machine learning model.
And David, remind
me what is MMSI.
DAVID KROODSMA: Marine Mobile--
AMY UNRUH: I could never
remember that acronym.
DAVID KROODSMA:
--Security Number--
Identifier.
AMY UNRUH: Yes.
DAVID KROODSMA: It's given
out by the International
Telecommunications
Union to boats.
AMY UNRUH: There you have it.
There will be a quiz.
So each such
identification, which
corresponds to a ship,
a stream of features
is being generated
for that ship.
And so this new
Dataflow pipeline--
it first aggregates
those for each ship
into a sequence that's
of sufficient length
to send to the trained
machine learning model.
And it responds with
indications suggested
by the blue-colored
cells here of where
it thinks fishing activity is
happening in that sequence.
So we know the time where it
thought fishing was happening.
We know the location.
And we used the learned
TensorFlow model and Cloud ML
to do that.
So then, the next
stage of this Dataflow
pipeline groups this information
by geographic region.
So I'm using a representation
called S2 geometry to group the
predicted fishing activity
into basically, like 1
kilometer square areas.
And so by doing that,
we get an indication of,
what's the magnitude?
It might be more than one boat.
What's the magnitude
of fishing in a given
area at a given point in time?
And then of course, we want
to analyze this over time.
And of course, the
magnitude might change over
time for a given square.
OK.
To do this-- now let's
start to look at the nuts
and bolts a little bit.
The first thing we did was
composed the two Dataflow
streaming pipelines,
connecting them by Pub/Sub.
So the first original feature
extraction pipeline, and then
this new pipeline.
To use Cloud ML Engine to do
prediction of fishing activity,
and then to do, basically,
location-based clustering.
So this is a really
useful pattern.
You can kind of think
of Dataflow pipelines
as like decomposable chunks of
logic, kind of like modules.
And actually, almost kind
of reminiscent in how
you hook them together
of Unix pipes as well.
You can compose them
together, you just
need to connect their inputs
and outputs essentially.
And the Dataflow pipelines
can have different owners.
They can even be in
different projects.
They can be written in
different languages.
And that was actually
the case here.
The original pipeline
was written in Scala
and the one I built
was written in Java.
And then, the means of
connection is Pub/Sub.
So something to
keep in mind then
is that Apache Beam's unified
model for doing both stream
and batch processing lets you
use these pipelines that you
build in different contexts.
Do you want to hook them
together in streaming mode?
Do you want to use
them in batch mode?
You can use essentially
the same pipeline for both.
OK.
So another key thing that
we leveraged to do this
is Apache Beam's
windowing model.
So if you think of
you've got an unbounded--
essentially, infinite
stream of data coming in.
And say it's colored tiles,
kind of like what's suggested up
top there.
And say you want to
group them by color.
You want to group all the green
tiles together and count them.
You want to group all the yellow
ties together and count them.
You need to do that in the
context of some defined window,
or else it's ill-defined.
It's an ill-defined problem.
So Apache Beam has really
sophisticated and flexible
windowing model.
It has different
kinds of windows.
For the second Dataflow
pipeline I built,
I used sliding windows.
And I mentioned this
earlier, it does something
that's really powerful.
It lets you say, do you want
a window by data arrival time
into the pipeline, or
do you want a window
and do your analysis
with respect
to when the data was
actually generated?
And so we're doing
it with respect
to when the data was
actually generated,
when the ship actually emitted
that bit of information
to the satellite.
Otherwise, we wouldn't get
good results, of course.
OK.
And then, the other
key piece then
is using the Cloud ML
Engine Online Prediction
Service and the learned
TensorFlow model
within our pipeline to
actually do these predictions.
So you can do this with
any TensorFlow model.
And you just need
to make sure that it
adheres to a certain convention
when you're building it.
This is spelled out in the
documentation, obviously.
When you're building
it, you need
to add certain input and output
collections to the graph.
And you can actually
do this kind
of post hoc, which is what I did
with the Global Fishing Watch
model.
I took the trained model.
I essentially loaded it
into a TensorFlow session,
added these new nodes that
were necessary for Cloud ML,
and then wrote it out again.
So you don't need to
do retraining again
to add these nodes to your
TensorFlow model graph,
if you've done any
messing with TensorFlow.
So after you train
your TensorFlow model,
you have to save it
in a certain way.
Basically, you need to
export it as a MetaGraph.
And then once you've
done those two things,
then Cloud ML Engine knows
how to deploy that model
and how to use it-- how to
serve it for predictions.
So that looks like this.
This gcloud, for those of
you who aren't familiar,
is the Cloud platform SDK.
So this is command line.
You first create your model.
That's just kind of like a
semantic tag for the model.
And then you deploy a version,
a named version of that model,
with a pointer to the path where
you saved the model once you
were done training it.
So you did your training.
Whether it was on Cloud ML
Engine using GPUs as David team
has been doing or
some other way.
You've got your
trained, exported model.
Now you point to that path
and this deploys your model
to the Cloud.
So then once you have done that,
and it's successfully deployed,
you can use it for prediction.
So you can do that
in all sorts of ways.
And you can do it just
from the command line,
gcloud ml predict.
And just feed it the
model input in the form
of, say, a JSON file.
Or you can do what I did
in this Dataflow pipeline,
is use the Cloud ML rest
API and send it data.
And call it directly from
the Dataflow pipeline
and get back the
prediction and use it
for subsequent processing
in the pipeline.
So I don't know if
any of you caught
the keynote this morning,
and the New York taxi--
very cool New York taxi demo.
But if you did, you
might have caught that it
was doing the same thing.
It was calling the Cloud
ML Engine Online Prediction
Service from a
Dataflow pipeline.
OK.
So just sort of one
more dive a little
bit further to look at
what's the UI for this.
If you were going to
build this, what would you
see in the Cloud console?
Here is that pipeline
happily running.
And you can see
the call ml engine
part is where we're
actually making
the rest API calls out to the
Cloud ML Prediction Service.
And then, we're taking
that information.
Basically, where do we think
fishing activity is happening?
And the rest of the
pipeline is grouping it
according to these
S2 geometry regions,
and then doing a streaming
right to BigQuery
to record what we have inferred.
So here is a dashboard
for the Cloud ML Online
Prediction Request.
So you can see, I'm kind
of like cutting it close.
I keep coming close to my
quota, but I'm carefully
backing off when I do.
So this just lets
you track what's
going on with your
deployed TensorFlow models.
And then, this last
tab here is BigQuery,
where all of this derived
information is getting written.
BigQuery has a streaming API.
And then we can use it
for whatever we like,
including building a map
like the one I showed you.
So I'm going to try to run this
query, just to kind of prove
that it's a live demo
that we're watching.
And so the processing
time is in UTC,
but you can see that
it's written [INAUDIBLE].
You can see UTC time.
That's relatively close
to our current time.
Those were just my
backup slides there.
All right.
So if we go back to
that sign pattern
that I was showing
you earlier, use
Dataflow to do pre-processing,
to do feature creation.
Shuttle that data off
to Cloud ML Engine
to do distributed
training, really--
highly scalable, use GPUs.
Now we can see there's
another piece of this
that is also very common, is
you've got your trained model.
You want to deploy
it, and then you
want to use it for prediction.
So that's sort of the
bottom part of this graph.
And in the lower left, that's
my new Dataflow pipeline,
which is using the deployed
model through the Cloud ML API
to get those predictions.
OK.
So just to summarize what I
did with the new streaming
pipeline, there were
a few cool things
that made it all fit together.
So the first thing was Beam's
unified batch streaming model.
There wasn't really
very much that
had to be done before I started
building on top of this.
So that was one thing.
The ability to easily
compose pipeline's,
kind of glue them
together, using Pub/Sub.
Beam's ability to support
reasoning about event time
in terms of when the
data was actually
generated, not when it arrived.
And then of course, Cloud
ML Engine Online Prediction
Service.
To use our trained model in this
new pipeline and get results
and just incorporate
it into the analysis.
OK.
So we covered a lot of stuff.
And from the Cloud
platform standpoint,
hopefully you've
gotten a sense of how
you can use these products
for real-world problems
in an interesting way.
How easy it was for
me to build on that
and extend and add
new functionality
without having to do a
huge amount of extra work.
And that there are some useful
design patterns that we've
talked about that come up
again and again when you're
building this kind of workflow.
DAVID KROODSMA: So I think
that brings us, more or less,
to the end of our talk.
And I just wanted
to take a step back
and say why I think
this is really exciting.
And as someone who's interested
in working on big data problems
to address the global
environment, what's
really cool about this
is we couldn't do this
five years ago.
Because we didn't
have the satellites.
We didn't even
have the data set.
And even if we did, we
didn't have this technology
to process it.
To be able to do--
these machine learning
techniques didn't exist.
And so we're really able to
make a huge leap forward now
compared to just
a few years ago.
And that's one of reasons
why I got up and really
excited to work on
this data set everyday.
And I think it's going to make
a real big difference in terms
of how we manage some of these
globally shared resources.
AMY UNRUH: OK.
So what's next, basically?
First, exciting news from
Global Fishing Watch.
I will let David--
DAVID KROODSMA: Yes,
we have-- so first,
we have a data website,
globalfishingwatch.oi,
companion to the .org site,
where you can download as much
of our data and code that
we are able to post there.
The main data set of
AIS is proprietary.
We have to buy it, so we can't
just share it with anyone.
But our code and a lot of the
derived data we can share.
And so we're making
it public there.
And also, just today,
we have made the repo
with this whole vessel
classification and fishing
identification, all
this machine learning
stuff we've been talking
about is all in that repo.
So you can go and
do this yourself.
And in fact, we even
have some training data,
which we've anonymized to
keep our data provider happy.
So you can't get the
name of the boat off it,
but you can actually
use that training data
to train the model itself.
So we are making some data
and the code available.
So you can go home
and do this yourself.
AMY UNRUH: And then
just from the standpoint
of the technology,
if you want to dive
into this a little
more, there's actually--
at Google Next, there's a bunch
of code labs as some of you
have probably
already discovered.
And there are some code
labs relevant to this.
I listed some of them.
And you can also just go try
them at home at your own pace
if you want to.
Make a note of that
bottom link and you'll
see all the code labs.
And you can just go poke around
and explore not only these,
but the whole range of them.
All right.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]